thank you thank you
uh welcome everybody it's always great
to be in berlin
and even more if it's attending years
confide i like it how
powerful and vibrant the community is
this is my second year
and it's not just a pleasure but it's a
great honor to be in this side of the
room
as a speaker and
well it's amazing first of all let me
tell you that
i have not watched inception and you may
be thinking which kind of person has has
not watched that movie and why is he
choosing the title then
well any possible reference to the movie
is just a plain coincidence
coincidence it is just that for this
particular talk i liked
how jas inception standard because this
talk
um is about implementing things of
javascript engines in javascript
and i wanted to use this very nice logo
that
i've been thinking to use for a while
which is all css and that i have been
tracking tweaking a bit after css comes
the other day
um so well this is
all html and some that was good but let
me introduce myself
as uh you know i'm adrian i'm from spain
but i live in helsinki
it's a bit funny i actually do enjoy the
winter
it's cold yes but it's very nice also
but that's all the things i enjoy a lot
one of them is free software
another one is getting into trouble the
first one
free software that's what got me into
igalia six years ago
and i'm working there still in the
compilers team and i hope for years to
come
the second part is what got me into
virtual machines and compilers
it's not the most useful thing for
people to like and it's
also maybe a bit of low level for gs
conf
but no worries we're not going to touch
almost any superstars called today
and yeah i said trouble because those
beasts
those beasts can be quite complex
um and lately the last year and
something we have been collaborating
with
bloomberg they have been supporting us
to bring
es6 features into javascript engines not
only v8 but also some spider monkey
and also modern layout to css
and if you have not watched it in css
conf i would recommend you to check out
the
gridlayout talk that from friday it was
very nice and it was amazing to see all
the
positive responses in twitter while the
talk was going on and it seems that it's
something people are going to like
that's very nice so in for today
i'm going to explain a bit what is this
inception thing about
how do we get the javascript into our
engine
mastectomy v8 and what we have time from
the
from the talk uh we'll keep trying to
come up with a small implementation for
a
feature of es6 try to add it to mb8 and
refine it a bit
as long as the as much as the time
allows
so there's going to be live coding i
hope nothing blows because this is the
kind of thing that can go
wrong well to make things even clearer
there's things i'm not going to touch in
this talk at all
this is not about transpiling this is
not about
changing javascript transpiling it from
es6 to es5
to current engines or anything like that
it is not about respecting other
languages to javascript it is not it is
not about implementing a javascript
engine in javascript itself that can be
done it's surely a lot of fun
and it's the kind of thing you do when
you have a lot of time
but we're more interested into getting
all things into actual process
and getting them in node.js get them in
places where people could use them
in established browsers so
this is more about adding features into
javascript engine
trying to touch the less of c plus plus
as possible
because the thing is once the the basic
virtual machine the engine is
the basics are implemented there's not
much that would prevent to use the
language itself
to implement things this is the same
that happens with c or c plus plus
you have the c compiler the c compiler
you can use it to build the c library
or to build the c plus plus library and
then use that in our program so why
wouldn't we use javascript
to implement parts of javascript or
parts of the standard library
or at least as much as we can and then
use that
in our own engine well
actually we can and there's a good
number of reasons to do that
i think we can all agree being in gs
cons that we prefer to use javascript on
c plus plus
it's easier it's a bit faster to develop
we don't have to
go with all this uh code compiled build
test
check the bar cycle so that gets faster
it makes us more productive and very
often the algorithms
are more easily understandable and more
maintainable
if we just write them down in javascript
and anyway there's another reason which
is
why i'm not doing it i can do it well
let's just do it just because
and that's one or two not so obvious
reasons
and one of them is that the modern
just-in-time compilers are really really
really good at generating machine code
they're so good that they can make
faster code that our handmade
cpus code and
how is it possible it's amazing well the
thing is that
if we implement parts of the runtime in
c plus plus there's still going to be a
moment
in which the javascript code has to call
into the c plus plus one time
and there there's two words there's the
javascript world there's the ziplex
class world
and whatever you use in the javascript
world you have to convert it you have to
convert the values to class plus values
arrange the stacks arrange other things
make sure you call into c
plus plus with proper calling
conventions this takes time
this layer this layer of butter in the
middle of javascript world and c plus
plus world
takes time if the functions i'm doing
are
likely to be well implemented by the
javascript engine
we would rather implement them in
javascript because we avoid all these
jumping from
javascript to c plus plus and that's
what makes it faster
also compile engines nowadays make very
good guesses about
types of things so you can just most of
the time not as well this integers
that's just generate perfect code for
integers
so yeah they make very good code so
there's no
there's no reasoning that would say yeah
let's make it plus c plus plus because
it's faster
it doesn't need to be and it may be
slower in c plus plus
and well anyway again just because
and because it's fun to give you an idea
of
how much javascript is using engines
this is from yesterday i made the
numbers yesterday
uh i've been checking the with um told
to count
lines of code that's
that's most of the javascript code is
using b8
next is spider monkey following very far
javascript core only one kilobyte
maybe they're trying to make one of
those one kilobyte javascript contest or
something
but well the fact is there's one reason
for that and is the javascript core
can revert to an interpreter so it
doesn't always
generate machine code so in that case of
course it's faster to use
simple runtime that you have to to call
into
so that it's my guess about why
why javascript core is not using more
javascript
of course these numbers are not counting
uh test suites
or tools etc so it's the runtime or the
parts of it that are implemented
in javascript so the uv8 looks like the
perfect match for this kind of
task and that's one of the reasons why i
have choosing
v8 for the this demo today
so i was saying what i don't implement
an es6 feature
so i've been checking until last week
which features
features from es6 are not just in v8
that
also they can be implemented in
javascript that also
nobody else is really trying to
implement them
to try to come up with something new
that it's not
done by anyone and there's one thing
that it's not done and it's a lot of
methods from type the race
which are well similar to the ones in
normal arrays but they just work with
type of arrays this kind of
hint 8 array in 32 array that have
contiguous memory baking and for example
uh those are
used by um asmgs etc
so for today let's implement
int something array for each
and well the code is very easy it's what
we could do in a polyfill
if we were patching the prototype
ourselves uh
there's one slide a small thing that is
not
handled by this function so let's see a
more spec compliant
version and is this a second argument to
for each that we can change the binding
of this for the callback
that is called for each of the elements
so this is actually
a version that we can go and implement
now
so let's do that
have some music for this
okay
okay let's reset this
so you can see in src inside v8
there's a number of javascript files and
there's one that is called typed array
that looks very good let's go there
type in array it's a javascript oh
surprise
great has well several things that look
a bit not so
much like javascript let's just go to
the end and patch
in our prototype
so for each is the function we're
implementing callback
this argument oops
functional keyboard that's important
well
if this is undefined then
not this but this the argument passed is
undefined then the spec says that these
arguments should be implicit this the
usual one for this function
so it goes that way let's make a loop
this is like all
most of the loops that go over a raise
this is this length
there so we call the callback we use
this
call function to change the binding of
this
and we pass the item in the position
there it's known can it really be this
easy
let's check it let's build it
it's of course only generating some
stuff building only the
building including the javascript into
v8
i'm going to talk in a moment about how
this works oops
extension or internal compilation error
hmm that doesn't look very good
maybe the javascript in here is not as
javascripty
as expected or advertised well let's go
let's look at it around
there's this setup data view for example
there let's small things here let's see
what it does
oh this is a bit funny okay there's more
things oh install get there hmm
maybe it turns out we cannot use getters
directly in javascript while we are
implementing things in the runtime hmm
maybe maybe let's see if there's
any other setup function set up type in
the race maybe we should move our code
here
well that's also install functions hmm
that looks good
but look at this it actually accesses
prototype here
and it uses global
probably there's some kind of module
system thing working on here
let's try adding this global in the
front and maybe it works
again the build phase is fast let's see
if it complies this time
blah blah blah this time it works that's
great
so amazing
we have just became v8 hackers
10 minutes who wants a full cs degree
and a compiler's masters
it's not needed let's just go fetch v8
now
start hacking house javascript in there
and well
make the engine do whatever you wanted
to do
all the linking is what takes more of
the time i should be building release
versions but anyway
it doesn't matter but i actually want to
show that it works
it sounds a bit strange that during the
compilation phase
it actually spits the errors and says
well i compiling this gasket
it actually is because
it makes sure that it's not going to
generate errors later runtime
and a kind of compiled version is
included in
the v8 library and there it is
now let's make an array
three elements for example so do we have
for each
whoa we have fridge
but hey we have to see if it works maybe
it doesn't work
for example we can change one of the
elements that's usual semantics
so let's see for each function what we
can even do for each print
hey it works wow so we have now a fridge
that works we implemented it in
javascript
it was pre-built into machine code when
building
what else we can ask for well
there are a couple of things we could
improve here
let me stop the music
there so that's a couple of things that
we would be tempted to do now because
there is not only into eight raiders
in 16 array in 32 array blah blah blah
all of those arrays that are typed
arrays so we would be tempted to do this
this would actually work we could patch
all the prototypes
what it's with a bit of work we have to
duplicate
those lines in the end but of course we
can do it
but these that's not it's not
necessarily a good idea
remember that the compiler doesn't is
not specializing one version of the
code for each function so it
it may fail and it gets its guess for
the types
so what we want to do is rather have a
copy
of each of the function that is exactly
the same code inside but
it's uh each one of the arrays gets its
own version
so when the compiler makes an optimized
version after doing
guessing the types it can do the perfect
version that matches
each one of the types
and now this is really starting to get a
bit tedious and a bit boring to write
all those
so fortunately i was saying there's some
strange things there in the javascript
code that v8 uses
they have a kind of macro expansion
thingy
that we can use to well to make one
implementation
that generates one copy for each of the
for each of the functions for each of
the right array types
and this is going to be good because the
code generated for each one of the
versions
once they get hot and they have been
used for a while and the types have been
guest
the code will generate this well the
best it can
so let's see how we can use that and i'm
going to board you again with the same
music
okay so let's go back we're still in
type of array there was a setup type
array up there
let's cut this let's go
set up type terrain there it is hmm
macro type of array array id name
element size
that looks like a it's generating copies
of things
and this name thing here has been
replaced
for what well for nami's replay is in
eight array name can be in sixteen array
let's
then move our version here
uh so paste
let's be nice and intended so instead of
intake array we write name
is that enough it seems so well now each
version of type of array supported by v8
automatically gets a for each
function in its prototype and each one
gets its unique version so this should
make it that
in each one of the type of array classes
their prototype has a fridge
at super let's see if there's any syntax
errors
or things oh that's an error again this
was not planned the other one was
so what's the problem here i don't think
it's the maybe it's that
it's a bit picky because the macros
tension is not very smart
so sometimes the arrows appear where
in places one doesn't expect
so let's see
aha now it seems to work yeah so be
be sure to always put colons and
semicolons and
all the daily miters you need because
you never know how the macular processor
is working
i have not checked the code it just
works sometimes makes things
we have the daily miters things work
again
ah we still out of time
if it sounds like elevator music it's
because it's almost elevator music
i had to make sure i was picking
something with free of rights and this
kind of things
while the eight is already built maybe i
can just randy it
i'm going to add harmony also
oh i'm usually nice probably it's not
marked exactly
with it that's a bit of a banner
if you want to hack in compilers get a
fast machine with lots of memory for the
linking
okay there we go i'm going to add
harmony this time
there we are let's see int 16
array prototype
for each oh yeah it's there let's see
will it work this time let's try again
within three array
yeah it works it seems to work let's
make another one next this time
u in 32 array two elements
for example b for each uh let's let's
let's try that
this argument handling works the second
parameter
to make it even nicer let's make let's
make this scenario function
so let's print these plus x
um let's pass a string for example why
not
hey it works wow amazing and narrow
functions are starting to work that's
so cool the don't don't rely on the
scoping of arguments and this so far
but it works and we got automatically
from a simple implementation from a
strong just one implementation
a copy of the of the function
in each one of the prototypes of all the
type of array classes
so that's super we could make it a bit
nicer we could use those install
functions
stuff we saw over there and then we once
it's nice enough we could send it for
review and get a deviate
and we are just one step uh one step
afar from being from being a person that
has a commit in a
javascript engine so i hope after this
talk you all go hacking your laptops to
start implementing all those missing
type of array methods it will get a bit
tough
with the review process but it's it's
going to be nice and you will be
also compilers hackers
there was those funny things in the v8
code
this is not the type of array i can
actually show this one
this is from normal array normal array
so we have the code for of for each here
and it has these
things there's this check audit coercive
there's this two object to i you in 32
but what was what is this
what's a javascript without types it's a
spec function
wow person sign get default receiver
well those things are there for a reason
um so there's certain things we should
know about the v8 runtime and
similarly happens to spider monkey it's
just that it's different
that's a different approach to certain
things because it's
not as fast to do everything in
javascript
or it's not possible to do all all of
everything in javascript because this
thing i was saying the initialization of
the
random library is done early during
initialization of the
of the javascript engine so there are
certain features that may not be
available
and also to implement certain parts of
the javascript specification
we need more information we may need if
to know if a function is a narrow
function
or a normal function and we can know
that an arrow function is an arrow
because
when we try to make new function it will
throw
and the normal one doesn't but throwing
a step shooting is
very slow or slower than just checking a
flag
so actually the runtime exposes these so
called
native functions which allow to
introspect
the runtime and the javascript code can
manipulate
and know more about the internals of the
runtime
so of course this is all implementation
dependent that's why it's different in
v8 and it's different in spider monkey
and the parser actually knows about this
that's a
low native syntax flag we can try those
things in the d8 interpreter
and that's a lot of functions there's
some helper functions
done in javascript those are the easiest
ones to check
so these helper functions are these ones
that don't have the
the percent sign and the functions
correspond
roughly to operations as specific
specified in the language specification
so for example there is in the
specification
there's a definition of what two object
is expected to do
and the algorithms in the specification
are written down using
uh as reference those basic operations
that are also implemented as helpers
here so the algorithms that exist in b8
most of them
try to mimic the algorithm the way it's
written in the
in the atmosphere the specification so
that's good because it's easier to
find how it corresponds to the spec
but it makes it a bit harder on us
implementing javascript
engines so i would recommend to just to
check this
to check this natives yes
runtime yes macros pi
and thus also the c plus plus functions
like this get default receiver this gets
what would be
these default arguments for a certain
function
so it checks chains and other things
that we have
that we have known implicitly when we
were doing the first implementation of
forage
and you can check those in runtime cc
and there's um fun
there should be a runtime function there
each random function is declared with
this macro
so for example there's a get scope count
it counts how many scopes there are
well you actually need to know a bit of
the engine
to go over those but with a bit of time
and checking
code examples from the rest of v8 is not
that difficult to get to use the same
constructs
as the as the engine really does so just
check the code in all the all the other
gs files
and try to follow the same style and
check the specification
the specification of javascript is quite
big it's something that may get into
your way
and it may look like a wall that's
difficult to go over because it's not
written in a very accessible language
so looking for examples in the rest of
the javascript code is better
and of course at some point you will
need to check the spec to make sure
things work as expected
um about b8 and how it's built
it took a bit uh actually it picks all
the gs
code puts it into a simplest plus file
as bytes that is linked
into alleviate no snapshot that is used
by
make snapshot which is a it's a small
utility that comes with v8 that is built
with
v8 base that doesn't include the runtime
and what it does is it generates the
code for it by loading
those javascripts and running them and
the
dumps makes a dump of the javascript
heap where the code is
and the variables and so and in a binary
format
that goes to a snapshot cc file and
that is built in then in v8 or v8
library
so it's much faster to load so if you
have
your standalone application that uses v8
you
can modify the bootstrapper.cc file
and include other files of javascript
that you have to you want to have
preloaded and pre-compiled
that are always available as soon as the
application starts
so that's something that is quite nice
to have
so well we're running out of time but i
still have a couple of remarks
as results of being here today with me
what i want you to be aware is that it's
not only c plus plus in javascript
engines
it's uh it's great to start hacking an
engine speaking
those slightly certain tasks in a
language that we may know better or we
may prefer like javascript
and you can pick your favorite engine
hack on it all of them use
javascript don't be
don't be scared of the spec ask go to
the
es discuss mailing list ask for
clarification sometimes the spec is not
clear especially
yes six parts that are still changing a
bit and sometimes you ask for a
clarification and some
someone comes and oh this is not very
well specified let's
give it another try so well
i hope i hope you are now all encouraged
to go
hack on the engines we need more people
like you to implement all of exma street
six
so thank you for coming here and thank
you for becoming
hackers